[Música]
y en directo América actualizamos la
información económica y por ello le doy
la bienvenida nuevamente a mi compañera
Daniela Blandón Hola Andrés Daniela
vamos a empezar en Brasil petrobras
causa fisuras en el gobierno de Luis
Ignacio urula da Silva Por qué Porque el
senador randolero Rodríguez quien es el
jefe de la coalición oficialista en el
congreso nacional y quien acompañó a
Lula en su campaña presidencial renunció
al partido red sustentabilidad este
partido fue fundado por la ministra de
medio ambiente Marina Silva una
reconocida ambientalista la historia es
la siguiente el gigante Estatal
petrolero quiere perforar pozos frente a
la desembocadura del río Amazonas en un
área denominada margen ecuatorial Allí
se cree que puede haber reservas de
10.000 millones de barriles de crudo
pero el regulador que es el Instituto
brasileño de medio ambiente negó esta
licencia ambiental porque no cuenta con
suficientes estudios para demostrar que
no va a haber impactos por ejemplo en el
sistema de arrecifes de este sector
petrobras dice que va a apelar Aunque de
fondo esto lo que hizo fue dividir al
gobierno Hay unos que se aferran a que
se debe proteger el medio ambiente y
otros como randolph Rodríguez que
defienden que el proyecto va a
beneficiar económicamente a la región
con regalías petroleras
Daniela las autoridades en Estados
Unidos alertan por airbags posiblemente
defectuosos pues la administración
Nacional del seguro del tráfico en
carretera se exigió el retiro del
mercado de 67 millones de infladores de
bolsas de aire porque cree que hay un
defecto de seguridad sin embargo el
proveedor de Este insumo clave para la
fabricación de vehículos llamado airct
automotive rechazó la solicitud la orden
es el resultado de una investigación de
8 años en la que se descubrió que estos
infladores podrían explotar tan fuerte
que podrían expulsar metralla de hecho
desde 2009 han muerto dos personas otras
siete han resultado heridas en Estados
Unidos y Canadá por esta causa
los infladores de bolsas de aire que
proyectan fragmentos de metal en los
ocupantes del vehículo en lugar de
inflar correctamente la bolsa de aire
adjunta Crean un riesgo irrazonable de
muerte y lesiones Bueno qué es lo que
responda la empresa ante esta situación
Pues esta firma con sede en Tennessee se
niega a retirar los airbags
supuestamente defectuosos del mercado y
se prepara para una posible pelea
judicial con la agencia de todas maneras
hay que tener en cuenta que estos
infladores de bolsas de aire están
presentes en múltiples líneas de
producción de al menos 12 fabricantes de
vehículos entre 2002 y 2018 entre ellos
están General Motors estelantes BMW
Hyundai y Kia ellos hacen parte de esta
lista Daniela vamos a conocer Los
indicadores
abrió al alza y en camino a cerrar su
mejor semana desde marzo con apuestas
muy positivas respecto a las
negociaciones sobre el techo de la deuda
en este país Aunque el mercado quedó
perplejo por el anuncio del ceo de
Morgan Stanley que es una de las más
grandes instituciones financieras en el
país de que la compañía probablemente
designará a su próximo sí o en los
próximos 12 meses en Europa la bolsa de
Frankfurt Está De Fiesta su principal
índice del dax 30 está preparado para
cerrar hoy en máximo histórico por
encima de los 16.000 puntos desde Japón
el presidente Joe biden los dejó muy
confiados en que estas conversaciones
sobre el techo de deuda van a llegar a
feliz término y en Asia del índice Nicky
tuvo su cierre más alto en 33 años tras
conocerse que la inflación en abril en
Japón se desaceleró al 3,4% anual bien
nuestra célebre cifra del día de mañana
tres mil millones de dólares que aprobó
el fondo monetario internacional para
gana este país que es uno de los centros
económicos de África occidental Busca
restablecer sus finanzas muy afectadas
por una vertiginosa inflación por su
moneda debilitada y también una deuda
pública en aumento que se está llevando
la mayor parte de estos ingresos Daniel
hablando con la información económica
Muchas gracias feliz fin de semana a
descansar y a recargarse para otra
semana que viene de muchas noticias